opening game of this traditional
doubleheader just be about tyler glass
now executing pitches and if he does
that he could very well get very deep
into this game swinging a mess at a
breaking ball out in front of the place
and you know blocks it and tags them out
there's strikeout number one for tyler
glass now and here's aaron judge and the
first pitch lifted high in the air down
the right field line
shallow in and towards the foul line
comes renfro and he's under it and
easily makes a gliding catch one pitch
and there's the second out two out of no
one on it leaves it for power hitting
mike ford grounded back towards glass
now let's it go though it's diaz the
third baseman behind the bag at second
to throw to first in time for the up for
garrett cole he has a 19-game winning
streak of nine game winning streak on
the road and here's a guy that is tough
against lefty's righties it doesn't
matter here's yandy diaz swinging the
ground ball right side and through base
hit mike ford didn't really get there
and it rolled through the right side and
the rays have their first base runner of
the afternoon and here's jimon choy
swing and a miss back goes all the way
to right field that that had some
serious distance on it cole strikes him
out
choy
is the first out of the first inning
well here's jose martinez struck kev out
swinging so there are two way two more
strikeouts for garrett cole
and here is yoshi
sugo and that's strike whoa what
blistering fastball at 98 right down the
pipe so cole gives up a ground ball and
then strikes out the side so after a
trouble free and very efficient first
glasnost allowed two hits and a walk to
load the bases in the second looks like
there's maybe some overthrowing going on
and a lot of fastballs sailing high see
if he can correct it quickly and that
brings up gary sanchez but he's just
three for 33. swinging a miss and he got
into chase ball forward thank you gary
sanchez that really helped that was
going to be a ball for run bad at him
now gardner swing and a miss he struck
him out he went off speed there brassno
dances through the range up comes out
dry number two out nobody order to leave
it for willy adams looped in the air
left center field jumping in a hurry and
it gets down for a base hit caught off
in the alley by gardner well he's going
to try for second and the throw is
offline a hustle double for willy adams
and a runner at second with two out and
here is the left hand hitting
centerfielder kevin kiermeier struck him
out swinging another fastball up so cole
has now struck out five until the
yankees get their third hit there's one
more than they had all last night now
here is left-hand hitting mike ford
almost 70 percent of the yankees run
score are via the long ball fly ball
right center there it goes see ya a long
home run for ford whoa did he crush that
two-run shot two-nothing yanks
there you go the reliance on the long
ball back-to-back walks four straight
hitters have now reached there's two one
and two out and here's geo swung on a
high breaking ball line to left center
there's a base hit in the gap rolling
toward the warning track and dropped by
tampa two runs will score
and the yankees take a four nothing lead
another big hit from geo and that is
indeed going to be it for tyler glass
now he just was not able to command his
pitches today well garrett cole and now
a very rich man with a four nothing lead
here's the ninth hitter right hand
hitting catcher mike zunino swing and a
miss
sixth strikeout for cole he's caught on
him miss slider down in the way and he
didn't come close
that strikeout is strikeout number seven
for garrett cole
has given up three hits and has struck
out seven and is enjoying a four-nothing
lead cut out of misty just do it by him
strikeout number eight for garrett john
carlos stanton who was singled and
walked scored once he will lead off
swung on and hit high on the air to left
field that ball is high it is far it is
gone
giancarlo hits one to deep left field a
stantonian
home run the yankees take a five-nothing
lead cole pitching a three-hit shutout
he has struck out eight breaking balls
cut out a miss strikeout number nine for
garrett mike zenino there's a swing in
the line shot hooked down the left field
line fairball for cenino all the way
into the corner and easily gets himself
a two base hit diaz the base hit his
first time strike three diaz thought
that was outside
instead it's strikeout number 10 for
cole jimon choy had a double to center
his last time up
will skip past the catcher sanchez
moving zunino over to third and the
count is full on joy ground ball that's
a fair ball up the right field line the
run scores and on his way to second
choice and the raids are on the board
making it a 5-1 game we know that aaron
boone is all in on the analytics but
he's a baseball lifer and he knows what
a win means because
i think if this was the sixth inning
they would have taken him out after that
double with and four pitches you know
leave poland to face jose martinez who
he struck out on sliders twice there's a
long high drive into left center field
talkman and gardner going back to the
wall gone
a two-run homer for jose martinez five
to three new york and garrett cole as
soon as he threw that that pitch he just
sort of leaned over on the mound and
squatted down with his head down and
that will be all for gary cole so cole
will not get his 20th straight decision
and le mayhew gives the yankees a good
start to the sixth he's head first and
here's aaron judge swung on and a
breaking ball hit in the air to deep
left it ball is high it is far it is
gone
a hanging breaking ball you could see
that coming oh here comes
the judge a two-run blast and the
yankees have a 7-3 lead and adam adevino
and the rays are down to their final
strike three ball game and the yankees
win game one of the double header
by a score of eight to four